ready to this morning's um public
engagement board
and i think you've got the short straw
again it's me
cheering and and the leader sends his
apologies
and if we can and
go through the attendance do people want
to say who they are so that people
are aware of who they are on youtube so
i'll start and then i'll
if you can just um i'll try and go
around this screen that i've got and
then if we can just all introduce
ourselves
that'd be really helpful i'm councillor
jane slater i'll be chairing today
i'm the executive member for health
wellbeing and qualities uh over to you
dorothy
i'm dorothy evans chief executive for
the african caribbean care group
uh i'm a local councillor for the green
party and my
representative award carl
um i'm khan mogul of the chair of the
voice of bme in trafford
debbie i'm debbie welsh i'm the director
of integrated services for talco
eleanor i'm eleanor roof and i'm the
director of public health for trafford
andrew andrew latham i'm the chief
officer of healthwatch in trafford
joe yeah i'm head of all age
commissioning
at trafford thank you donna
i am don sega i'm a consultant in public
health
laura laura hobbs
i am the uh program lead for covert 19
team
tom theory
health surveillance analyst
martin
martin pritchard countable officer nhs
trafford clinical commissioning group
tom maloney morning everyone
uh tom maloney program director of
health and care for the council
and the dcg louise
morning so sorry i've got some builders
here so i might just
um i'm louise wright i'm the sport and
physical activity relationship manager
and i'm here to give an update on the
age well board
martin dylan
i'm martin dylan comms and marketing
manager for trafford council
tracy hi i'm tracy clark i'm constant
engagement specialist at traffic
clinical commissioning group
and fabiola
yes sir governance officers traffic
council
thank you very much and does anybody
have any declarations of interest
so see no indication so we'll move on to
the minutes of the last meeting
um i actually chaired that meeting so
i do know that the minutes look fine to
me but are there any
matters arising or um has anybody got
any
questions around the minutes of the last
meeting
no so we can agree those oh debbie
yeah just to say on the air front cover
um i actually i'm actually employed by
uh traffic local care organisation not
traffic ccg
oh sorry about that we'll get those
updated thank you
okay so uh moving on we'll uh to item
four it's an update on the current cove
19 situation and eleanor if you could um
take that please thank you
okay thank you um yes so you've got the
report in front of you
um as you know this is a fast moving
situation
although i think um the relative good
news that we have at the moment
is that i think our rates are
stabilizing in trafford although
they are stabilizing at a much higher
level at over three hundred thousand
three hundred per hundred thousand at
the moment still
we're now 36 in the country um
the biggest concern i have is that we're
actually seeing a stabilization of our
rates in our
um under 15s which is good news um a
drop
in that um 17 to 21 year old age group
and stable rates in the 30 to 64 age
group but the most worrying thing is
that we're actually starting to see
a fairly steady rise in our um in cases
in our over 65
population and that's the population
that is most likely to be severely
affected if they do get covered
so i think um while it's good news that
our rates aren't continuing to go up in
the rate at the
rate of increase we had um the concern
is that we are still seeing these very
high rates across the board
and that we have um rates over 300 a
hundred thousand
in clifford ward in hale barnes in
ashland on mersey and stratford and
altering them in armstrong
so we're really seeing this spread right
across the borough
um continued spread of high cases um
high number of cases
and as i say that increasing incidence
in our over 65 year olds
because they're the most likely people
who will be seriously ill
who will end up in hospital and who
could even die of it
so i think we do need to be i think the
main message from our data at the moment
is we're at a very difficult position
still
we all do need to think about how we
protect ourselves and how we protect
other people
from um from covid and and the best way
to do that
continues to be those same messages
about
um social distancing keep two meters
away from anybody
if you have any symptoms get a test
self-isolate while you're waiting for
that test
result please don't mix with other
people in your household should also
self-isolate if any of you are
symptomatic
while you wait for that test result um
and
really you know the highest risk places
do remain crowded indoor venues
noisy venues and poorly ventilated
venues
so please do try and make sure you you
know you avoid venues that feel
feel at all unsafe and um the
the advice on household mixing remains
the same please you know just think
try and limit the number of people you
see and if you come if you can
go outdoors go for a walk with people
please don't go in their houses at the
moment
anyone got any questions thank you
and me first i'll abuse the position of
the chair
um i was reading some comments and stuff
from people over the weekend and it
concerned me that people that seem to
think that they can have
multiple bubbles with different people
um and you know oh i've been to this
bubble this time and i've been to
i've been where i've been with in this
bubble here so i
do think that perhaps some of our comms
may need to be a bit clearer around what
the bubble situation is and you can't
have
you know bubbles in with every household
that you um
that you feel like and i think that some
people are a bit confused around the
rule of six as well so i think that if
they go out on friday night with six
people they think they can go on
saturday night with us
with a different six uh group so i just
think that if we can have some
um some clearer comms around that i
think it'd be really helpful thanks
i think i think you're absolutely right
i think i think some of the work
wording about the households as well
people get a bit confused and they think
that's whole households but actually you
need to think of each of the people in
your household as an individual
each of you has your own individual
risks and so each of us needs to be
thinking about how we reduce our
personal risk
and that does mean limiting the number
of people we we see
um and i'm thinking of course that if
you do you know
where are you if you did get infected
who are the people that would be your
close contacts
um and making sure that we're really
clear about who those are
and that we we share those details with
people so really if you are going within
two meters
of somebody you need to be thinking if
i'm going within two meters of them i'm
prepared to self-isolate for them
um so and and and thinking about that
big
you know how in a household of four or
five people if you're each seeing
six people on different days that gets
to a very big group of people very
quickly
and at the rates of um infection we have
you know that there are p
and and the fact that it's um you know
with the best will in the world it's
very hard to stop yourself getting
passing on it on in the asymptomatic
phase if you've got no idea you've got
it
it's very hard to stop the only way you
can stop yourself from passing it on or
picking it up from somebody asymptomatic
is by keeping that social distance and
um
by seeing fewer people because that way
you're less likely to bump into somebody
who is
um unfortunately carrying the disease at
the moment
but i agree i think i think the um i
think the messaging has got confusing
and i think and i do think as well lots
of people are very tired
and are wanting to see people and we can
understand that and it is about making
sure you know it's not about not seeing
anyone but it's trying to do that as
safely as you possibly can
and just thinking about the risk um and
acting accordingly
thank you does anybody have any
questions for ellen
nobody's indicating so thank you very
much for that um if we can move on to
um item five which is the um ten point
plan
and um items a and b they're going to be
taken by
laura thank you laura
sorry just unmute myself um
so updates from our kind of covid
coordination engagement group and our
enforcement group who um
are waiting meeting regularly now on
monday morning and looking at the data
that's been presented to you
and kind of proactively trying to
support the work of this board to try to
make sure that we're doing as much as we
can with the the community
and our engagement efforts um so loads
of work this week
to try to understand the new national
tier system and what this means
and how it applies in the various
different sectors so
housing businesses and open spaces
and there's lots of kind of active
communication with system partners and
key stakeholders to make sure that the
messaging's clear and we understand what
it means to be in tier 2
and then of course moving into tier
three we'll be doing lots of work around
that this week as well
um there the crime and anti-social
behaviour team
are working to make sure we've got the
public space protection orders in place
across the town centre
and to prevent kind of clustering at 10
o'clock so i think there's been a lot of
work with
off licenses and supermarkets at kind of
pub
kick out time so work to make sure that
you know we're not having clustering and
drinking on the streets
and the team are looking at plans for
halloween and bonfire night
um so they're kind of upcoming to make
sure that we can kind of
actively manage these and it's around
like identifying the legislation that we
can use to sort of prevent any public
displays from
from taking place um ongoing work with
transport for greater manchester on face
covering compliance
on public transport um and
uh also around um gmp
and uk border control are kind of
working together around
the quarantine rules and people
returning from from
countries and how we can make sure that
that you know we
get reports through of um from schools
etc
uh where we know that the people have
been away and they aren't compliant so
it's just trying to understand how we
can implement that
of course there's a huge kind of
resource implication of all of this work
for our kind of enforcement team
so it's trying to understand kind of the
priorities in the system and working to
those
um our public health team last week met
with
mosque leaders in the north of the
borough
and arabic school teachers and we
are kind of proactively one of our data
leads in our public health team has been
um
has been translating uh materials into
urdu
um so that we can send those out those
weight this week
so um stuff around uh the test and trace
support payment of 500 pound for people
that might lose
income um normal missions eating around
wash
hands cover face keep keep space all of
that kind of stuff making sure that
we've got it in kind of key languages to
support our local communities
and then it's about kind of building
those localized networks to make sure
that those messages are being
disseminated to faith leaders and
activists
in in the borough um lots and lots of
work
around schools and i'm sure elena can
kind of provide an update um
around that so supporting kind of head
teachers
where we're having outbreaks and what
that means in terms of implementing that
in practice
uh where we have essentially bubbles and
where
multiple people have to self-isolate as
a result there's loads and loads of work
um i think we've had probably outbreaks
in the majority
or we've certainly have covered positive
cases in in a substantial
amount of schools across the borough so
there's loads of work um from the public
health team going into that
um and then ongoing work really with
kind of engaging with business owners
and
managers where outbreaks occur in the
workplace is making sure that we've got
kind of covered secure workplaces and
again what it means when we've
identified a
an outbreak um
kind of continuing to circulate our
stakeholder briefings
to businesses community safety and
partnerships team and communities
and we've got some work ongoing at the
moment we've got cabinet office
who is helping us to develop some
posters
in different languages and they're
supporting as well
and they've got a team of people from a
resource perspective who are going to
support to kind of distribute those
around the high prevalence areas of the
borough
well high prevalence areas we're doing
some work to sort of
understand where we would like um those
that resource to kind of go so we're
kind of looking at maps of the region to
to work out where we do those leaflet
drops
and then internally within the council
we are trying to kind of leverage the
support of our 2500 strong workforce to
be
kind of champions and advocates on all
this messaging because i think
there is um lack of clarity
as to what what it means to be in tier
two tier three and there's obviously
been a lot of change hasn't there
uh over the last however many months so
we're looking at doing some sessions for
staff
making sure kind of every contact counts
and how we can kind of leverage the
support of our workforce in
in some of this key and messaging and
communication
um i don't know eleanor or martin martin
from a commons perspective is there
anything else or tracy
that you want to add
now i think you've pretty much covered
it there uh
one thing i would add is we're doing a
facebook live events
on thursday with elena and with mark
jarvis from
the ccg so we're inviting questions from
the public around
coronavirus so that's happening on
thursday it's seven o'clock
thanks martin thanks very much laura for
that update and does anybody have any
questions for
laura or any questions around cons for
martin
dorothy yeah it's just with the um the
over 65
age range um i know you've done um some
briefings
generally but how are we making sure
that we get the message
out to them because they're going to be
the age range
that are perhaps meeting with younger
members members of their families
and it's about their potentially the
ones that are going to be shielding
and as we go into the the different
tiers i'm sure there's going to be a
level of confusion
so how are we going to to manage the
messaging to them
i think a lot of people are really
really frightened at this point in time
and i think it's about
getting the messaging right
i don't know if that's a good segue into
the age well board update
um because there is a lot of work i
think louise and her team are doing lots
of work with
with that older population um unless
eleanor you've got
i know i think it is a very good segue
into the age well work when louise can
talk about but um dorothy i think you're
absolutely right it's
really critical that we get those
messages across and that we need to make
sure that that reaches all of our older
people
and it's that mix between you know we do
want people going out for walks and so
on we don't want
people sitting in their homes being
frightened um but at the same time
the rates going up in that age group
does mean that not only are they risk
you know obviously there's risks from
younger people but also
there's risks from people in their own
age group so it's making sure that when
they are out with people in their own
age group
that they do keep that social distance
um but we do want to make sure that
people don't put themselves
by staying inside you know you're
putting yourself at greater risk of
things like
falls um general lack of fitness
and so on which will will make you more
susceptible as well
so i think it's trying to make sure that
people have as active as life as
possible
while um trying to limit their exposure
to
people who may be infected um and that
that is a very difficult message to get
across i know
so the more we can do and louise i think
we'll be able to talk about the work
with the age well board so
and but any insights that people have
particularly from
from that age group and from different
communities within it would be really
valuable
do you want to come in and respond to
this
question and then do you want to just
actually will the swap c and d around so
if you just want to do
your update now whilst you've got the
floor that would be great thanks a lot
great thank you and morning everyone i
think hopefully this
the update should answer the questions
and vice versa but um
the age well board is looking to recruit
a number of community champions
um who are in essence they'll be kind of
the older the boys for older people in
the borough
um and we really see this as sort of
people being the eyes and ears of older
people in the borough but also
helping us to share some of the key
messages because
i think you know as we all recognize
it's you know vital that we get
these key messages out there so um we've
got a very active member of the age
world board who's currently working with
the um
community hubs and looking to sort of
recruit a number of champions from
across the borough so that we can be
sharing these messages
and we've got a key number of priorities
so
there is obviously a lot of work around
the winter messages
but also how we can encourage people to
sort of
be active digitally and staying
connected that way
and so we're very much sort of looking
at the opportunities
that that we've got across the borough
to to really
you know engage all the people whether
it's through technology through sort of
the contacts and the connections that
they have
with their friend friends and family
recognizing that obviously it's
difficult to
socialize at the moment so um
yeah any contacts or connections you
know
anything that people want to share would
be would be great but
yeah this is a priority for the age
world board at the moment so
thank you um
so if we just move back to c then and
that's and tracy would you be able to
just give us an
update on the um health and social care
steering group work please
okay sorry it's tom here you want me to
go with that tracy
go on time perfect
thank you and so it's only a very very
quick
um eight plagues um raise
pieces of work which tracy has been
leading on um
though to mention that we took the uh
communications and engagement strategy
for health and social care
to the traffic health and well-being
board me where we met on friday last
week
and they were supportive of that so
that's fantastic news that ties together
the conversations we've been having in
the public engagement board now for the
last number of weeks
and a great progress there and the work
that laura's described previously around
the engagement board the virtual network
and all the communications effort
they're also having to leave within that
so that's great um it's probably also
we're just building on
um martin's comment before which was
around the
um thursday session at 7pm for the
facebook live session
i wanted to bring people's attention to
the fact that we've actually now
launched um and martin may want to jump
in here and talk a little bit more about
it because he's
been a lot more involved than i have um
bought the brand new
dead some caring trafford that's been
created by
um the panic that they exist within this
forum and beyond
um which is a an unbelievable
opportunity to get messages out there
and consistently which is really really
important isn't it and reach lots and
lots of people and
through that virtual network on facebook
and
martin is there anything else you wanted
to mention on that or anyone else who's
been more directly involved
don't forget that is jamie's been in
touch with partners uh
encouraging them to supply consequence
for that so hopefully that's going to
develop
over the next the next few weeks and be
a source of information for
everyone across the border
add something yes please yeah um it will
also be really key
to ask people if they wish to send in
questions as well so on the facebook
page the nhs and karen trafford we are
asking for people to send questions in
to us
and then um eleanor and
mark will be looking at those questions
and responding to as many as they can
so it really is key to try and get as
many questions as possible
and that will be for our partners here
in this meeting will be great
thank you tracy and does anybody have
any questions
no and i think you were the point you
were making about and some of our
hard-to-reach communities that's really
important so
if the well uh if the board can um look
to see
if they can speak to residents before
the event on thursday and
get perhaps get some of those questions
over to you i think that'd be really
helpful so that we can answer as much as
possible and
obviously if people who in those
hard-to-reach communities haven't got
access to facebook if they are asking
questions if we can
and have some other response back to
them so that they could you know feel
engaged as well i think that'll be
brilliant but thanks everybody that was
really really helpful
so we're moving on to item six which is
um
public engagement boards activity so i
think
since the last time we all met i think
you've all been very active and it's um
it's been very interesting some of the
some of the um items that you've bought
today but are there any other
um things that you believe that we
should be bringing to the board i don't
know if
eleanor you've had any questions or
anything around that
no i think it really is i think just
thinking about how do we make sure that
we get the messaging right and that we
get the reach into the different
communities
and really the purpose of this board is
to make sure that
um this board is giving us the insights
to reach those um um communities that we
might have missed or that
maybe the messaging is being
misunderstood or or misheard
but the um and the other thing is that
um
really to make sure that this board is
happy with the steps that we're taking
um as a as a council and and ccg
to to make sure that we are getting that
reach into our communities
so it's really both a um plea to the
board members to help us
with where they feel if they feel
messaging isn't being understood or if
it's not being put in the right
sort of language it's not being framed
correctly please let us know and we'll
try and adapt it
but also um if there are ways that ideas
that people have of
supporting us with getting that
messaging out
because i think i think you know
whichever tier we're in and goodness
knows what will have happened by the end
of today or tomorrow or whatever
i think the main thing is that the virus
doesn't care what's here we're in
the virus just likes to go from human to
human so we do have to do everything we
can to try and
stop it from spreading and do what we we
can do and support that messaging going
out
while at the same time pushing forward
that message which is really important
about our health services being safe
you know if you need to see the doctor
you need to see the doctor please do
make sure
if you have symptoms of anything else
you know call your gp
talk to them don't avoid other getting
other treatment because we absolutely do
not want to see
preventable deaths um at this time or or
conditions getting worse so it's really
how do we manage people's self-care
how do we manage making sure people
trust um and feel safe in our health
services
because those services are safe we are
really doing and i don't know if martin
wants to talk a little bit
about what we're doing to make sure that
our services are coded secure
but it really is that plea to think
about what you can do to keep yourself
safe
um keep what you could think about what
you can do to improve your own health so
that will be about more physical
activity
you know now is a great time to stop
smoking think about
if you drink alcohol making sure you
don't go over the limits
all of those things and also if you have
signs and symptoms that you're worried
about
absolutely please do make sure you
contact your doctor
thank you all and martin and i you
wanted to come in martin pritchard
thank you um eleanor actually started to
pick this up and absolutely recognize
that the
the virus doesn't really care which tier
we're in but
given the conversations that are going
in eleanor
how does our messaging change if we were
to move into a different
tier and are we prepared in terms of the
messaging that we're putting out
because it feels like it is a a
fast-moving situation it's hard to
predict doesn't it
it is hard to predict and i think our
messaging i think our main messaging
probably stays the same that
um you know that absolutely we are
wanting to do everything we can
to support people who may need to be
shielding if the
if the advice changes on that and we
will communicate with those
people um we obviously have the options
now
around um support to people who are on
low incomes who are self isolating
but i think my main message is that the
critical point now is to try and stop
the roots of transmission
and to get the numbers of people down so
it really is right if you
the the main advice whatever we end up
in will be the same it will be that
um if you are positive if you if you are
symptomatic
get a test self-isolate while you wait
for the results
and if you um if you know that people
you know are contacts
um please give those people's names and
i know there's been
concern about whether what would be
shared with the police
and so on and i think i mean in this
country we we do police by consent
and so really we do want to get people
to engage with this i think that the
the idea of the enforcement there will
be enforcement i think that i think that
will be in rare situations um
and we do want to try and just get
everybody to be thinking about how do
they protect themselves and others
and that's the main message i would be
getting through trying to get to people
it's not about you know if you don't do
this though you know people will be
arrested and so on it's really about
if we don't all change our behavior a
bit
people are going to be seriously ill and
that will have terrible consequences for
all of us so it's really thinking about
how we all do our bit
to um to change our behavior to limit
the number of people we see
um and to look after ourselves and other
people
and that will be the same whichever tier
we're in
thank you elena and does anybody else
have any further questions tom i know
that you've put
um a message in the chat do you want to
just
um let people know about that so that
we've actually got it recorded for the
youtube thank you
yes absolutely so again this is um this
is through the efforts of the
communications
engagement group and
on the public engagement board and one
of the big pushes we wanted to do was
around self-care week um
from the 16th 22nd of november and
that's one of those proactive
campaigns that makes a difference as
everyone has already alluded to
in early running and just to make sure
that people's
people are aware of that and can help
and contribute the online conversations
that we want and where possible all the
other engagement
that we'll we'll do as planned as a
partner and we'll be in touch with
people through the relevant groups that
we've got in place for everyone to play
their part in that
thank you thanks tom i think that brings
us on quite nicely to
the uh item seven because i think uh
public engagement board is due to meet
on the 15th of november so
people can have a think about what we
can do around the um
16th to the 22nd i think that's an
opportunity for us to to get that
information so i think that
so if people have got ideas about how
they think that we can support
um self-care we think that if you can
bring them back or obviously send them
in that'll be really helpful is there
anything
else that the board feels that we um
need to discuss today around
issues are we escalating things
correctly okay eleanor thanks
i just wanted to give a piece of good
news on a slightly different matter
but i think it's really important
because it changes shows how people can
that behavior can change and that is
that we've seen a drop in the number of
people smoking in trafford
um and so that is tremendously good news
because
smoking remains the big biggest single
um preventable cause of premature
mortality in this country
fifty percent of people who smoke will
be killed by smoking
so the more that we can do to um support
people to stop smoking and the more
people can do themselves
to to try and stop smoking the better
and now is
absolutely the time so again um linking
in with us there are stops making
services and traffic we are
we are looking at how we improve those
as well but it's really just to say as
part of that self-care
if we can just make sure that we we do
keep our
support people to stop smoking um we do
really well
always with our pregnant women um in
traffic
really low rates of smoking in that
group but we've also seen drops in other
in other groups so um that's a piece of
really good news
um and it's just really to say let's
let's build on that
um keep those making rates down and get
our physical activity rates up and that
will be a fantastic contribution
to keeping people healthier thank you
elena that is really good news because i
know that you've done some
quite detailed work in partings in a
little while ago so
you know it it's it's it's um you're
getting the benefits now of
some of that work thanks thank you very
much and is there anything else that
anybody would like to say i know it's
been a bit of a whistle-stop
um meeting this morning but i haven't
been
notified of any other business but you
know happy to take comments from anybody
or
you know any ideas and yes michael
please
um just a building on what eleanor was
was just saying then if we're
campaigning on
you know we will welcome reduction in
the number of people smoking but
obviously we have a
an air pollution problem as well and do
we need to be having more of a public
campaign on
on that making people aware of their of
of their own contributions to the
air pollution problem in their vehicles
when you know in their transport choices
i know that we're putting a lot of
messaging out
um you know proactively promoting active
travel and saying please
but we're not really giving people the
reasons why they need to do that
and maybe it's time that we actually
need to to to to give more
a bit more of a hard-hitting message on
that so people know what they're exposed
to in their cars
what their you know and what they're
causing when they when they when they
drive
i i agree and you know i think that
living very close to the a56 i think i
know
quite you know firsthand what the
pollutions could like in stratford we do
have a continuation
of a motorway through our town so you
know um
the cycle lane luckily had stayed within
stretford so
our like our lanes are down to um to two
and we do have um three primary schools
that are actually
very close to the a56 in stratford you
know so we do
we do need to be um getting that message
out that if you don't need to use your
car
you know think of an alternative um way
of if you you know to
to get to somewhere and we need to know
the reasons why as well
we need to know that people need to know
the reasons why as well beyond you just
just just beyond you know beyond the
social distancing messaging that's
that's gone out so far you know and and
also to to
to for that to chime in with you know
with
with some more maybe some more uh
awareness about the uh the message from
the anthocys report recently regarding
the
you know the need for 13.4 carbon
reductions year on year
you know that message has not gone out
at all yet
to the um you know to the community
there's only uh only people
who have read that report counsellors
and and council members will be actually
aware of that
so far and that you know i think
the combination of this message that
message needs to go out
um and you know we need people need to
know about it
if they don't know about it then they're
probably not going to change their
decision you know they
change their choices and decisions and
you know and we're not going to get that
immediate
response to the air pollution crisis at
least until the um you know
until the uh until the big
air plan comes into force in a couple of
years time
i think i've seen some conferences quite
recently around and you know the
emissions charges
i'm sorry croaky this morning and the
admission charges in
uh that coming through greater
manchester united i think that that'll
start an engagement of people
to say well why is it happening and then
understanding actually
it's because a lot of buses lorries etc
cars
you know all the cars are polluting our
and our
towns and kanji do you want to come in
and i can see ellen is also indicating
i think valerian is talking about the
same subject letter do that then i'll
make a comment later on
okay i was just going to say that we did
quite a bit of comms around clean air
day
um and including making that link to
covid i think i think one of the
difficulties has been that the kovic
conversations
have have squeezed out a whole load of
other things that are actually probably
of longer term
enormous interest so i absolutely agree
with you i think we need to be getting
more comments out
and i'll talk to martin dillon we have
done some comms but we just need to make
sure that
those are all properly linked on the
website and so on and that people have
access to them
and um and absolutely that point about
active travel now is the best time
ever for active travel because not only
will you reduce your own covert risk by
becoming more physically active but also
you improve the air quality
um which reduces the risk for everyone
so
um mata i'll speak to martin dillon and
we'll we'll look at
what the comments we've done and whether
we should what else we add to that
thank you eleanor and i've noticed in
the chat that donna's actually
given us a link for the um live well
smokey uh quit smoking so if we can get
that up onto the
website and make it available for people
and that'd be really helpful thank you
donna
uh khan did you want to come in i just
want to bring in a general point
uh having talked to many people in the
bam communities
uh i think most people although they are
concerned that we might be going to tier
three
many of them actually appreciate the
work which is being done by the local
council
and they seem much more comfortable
and much more reassured that
their health issues are being taken
seriously and that is why i think many
of them don't want to get into tier
three
and just a general point from the
communities
they're quite happy that the greater
manchester authorities are standing firm
on this against the westminster thank
you
thank you khan and you know obviously if
we end up in tier three we've got to
make sure that people
are paid correctly so that we don't end
up having
further problems i know if people
haven't got any
money to pay the rent and stuff we're
going to be in a terrible situation so
thanks for that update
and are there any more questions or
comments that anybody would like to make
tom was that you indicated no
no what are you scratching your ear i
think that's what it was
sorry okay um
well thank you everybody you know it's
been really helpful and
we you know we'll we'll have a look at
the comms and we'll get that information
around
um quitting smoking and thanksgiving to
all the officers for the contributions
today it's really
you know it's really good the work that
you're doing and you know and thank you
to our partners for speaking to our
communities
and if we can get that information and
back for our next board
of how we're gonna you know continue to
bring everybody up to speed and include
everybody that'll be really great so
thank you so much and see you next
i think it will be you'll be seeing me
next time as well
so see you next time thank you
thank you thank you bye bye